we're back to messed that one up badly
we got questions to get back to so wait
we just started a YouTube channel
we just started you so this is the live
public link for those who talk to them
that we're in a different jet hey we're
here okay sorry for losing you guys
there I totally forgot to put my phone
on airplane mode so no calls came in and
that through the whole thing out of
proportion but can you guys hear us okay
yeah okay good we're good we got some
questions that we were totally in the
middle of answers I was like wait a
minute we're not connected anymore
whoever we talk who was the question we
were answering John Brittney Lange's
right which TV show would we like to
come back okay Brittney Lange
alright cool we're just gonna pick this
right out where we left off all right so
yeah just in closing I think it would be
great I started again we got cut off all
right I want king of the hill to come
back partly because it's one of my
favorite shows of all time but I think
over 14 seasons they managed to have a
great level of consistency really well
realized characters and I feel like the
sensibility of the show the kind of
commentary and the kind of humor would
be very well suited to the now in these
times that we live in I would love to
see what Hank and company would react to
all the crazy [ __ ] that's happening in
the world right now I don't know I I
miss that show deal but she was talking
about coming back as a reboot not coming
back on the air you're you're describing
sort of like a WoW air at the ground
guys thanks so much man all over the
comments what really we gotta get to you
um but Britney laying come I guess a
comeback as a reap yeah because you're
describing sort of a like a Will & Grace
or a Family Guy
yeah your Bible a different reword yeah
but a reboot in and of itself
mm-hmm that's what no
[Laughter]
I think you should reboot friends with
everyone being a different ethnicity
except for the the main character Rachel
should be white still but everyone else
is a clearly a supporting character and
is like black Chinese Arab but the main
character is still white we cannot lose
that as the essence I hope everyone's on
board for me in this chat
I seems to be no feedback and I think
that silence tells me enough known and
everyone agrees with me Wow seven people
dropped off right when I made that joke
well my revival answer will be Batman
the Animated Series I feel like you can
still continue that in such pure fashion
but my genuine answer as a reboot I
think they should reboot iron fist on
the Disney Plus show right the [ __ ] away
that would be my best but that would be
the one I want to see done immediately
and then who hosted we got that we had
before get on him Fanny Hoffman asking I
heard they're remaking Stephen King's
The Stand is it true I'm gonna Google
that yeah thanks for the super chat on
that question there yeah I mean you know
you could have just googled that
yourself CBS is doing it and that's how
if there's any other yes or no questions
that we want us to Google and a super
chat format feel free to just send that
our way that's no problem at all people
and then John who else are we got here
big was up of $5 from Eric the grounding
appreciate that buddy Carter Lovejoy who
will be crowned box-office champion
Rises the Skywalker or cats I would
actually love it if cats just happened
to dethrone are like totally beat out
rise at this guy log I would love it if
it WTF won the weekend or the Christmas
holiday really and yeah just stole it
I'm not gonna lie I'm probably not even
gonna watch cats I'm going to I have
close to zero interests in that movie it
was it was one of those things that when
I watched the trailer I saw the trailer
on the way to Comic Con just watching
the car I'm like I don't
about this and I was like man looks
terrible then suddenly all these
dislikes that became the most hated
trailer to come out or that week I'm
still in that train of like I I just
don't think I'm ever gonna pull myself
to the theater to to sit through that it
seems like the kind of movie I'd want to
talk through the entire time I'm
watching it and you just can't do that
in theatre format you know I'd want to
be respectful still while in my my
Cineplex you know what I mean yeah we
also got well I know if we caught this
Brandon and son wanted to know who is
y'all's dream pic for the next Wolverine
ooh you know oh who is the guy that we
saw from that Vikings clip oh damn I
don't remember his name the guy played
Ivar the boneless yeah I think he would
be a great one Ivar the boneless that
would be a great pick he got a menace
about him but also like the charm yes
that would be epic and it would
definitely be different flavor cuz I
would want someone who's like short and
stocky and a little bit more brutal and
someone who could actually train as some
gymnastic skills Statham yeah it would
be great yeah yeah I want someone who
embodies a little bit more of the
comic-book appeal it's it seemed like or
resemblance I felt like Hugh Jackman
other than the hair and the attitude
like the performance yeah like Logan is
right there as one of my top like three
favorite comic book movies ever but you
know the the initial look wasn't exactly
Wolverine he morphed more into looking
like Wolverine as time went on I want
someone who does have a little bit of a
short stocky ER appearance look yeah who
isn't afraid to be a little shorter than
everybody else yes I don't think Taron
Egerton I've heard a lot of people throw
his name around as much as a beautiful
actor as that guy is I do not think him
you know Eric the the ground the
grounding guy do you have a question for
us that's us a question yes it was I
mean appreciate the contribution but
this seriously is a question you're
bringing the party man
you are you're so you you're what's up
the king wants to know listen up what
are your thoughts on the MCU moving
forward into the future
well what I
I would only go to the past all periods
yeah reboot Iron Man reboot captain
reboot phase one right away well the
clear answer is Danny DeVito that's a
phone Manji clearly went on the short
and stocky yeah yeah you son of a [ __ ]
okay
MCU moving forward into the future you
know what I'll point this oh this might
not be the answer at all the answer
you're looking for I found this very
interesting that's talking with someone
about this recently how when they
announced phase four of Marvel they
never mentioned the the next Avengers
movie or when the next Avengers movie
would be coming out which i think is
such clever marketing on there and
because if they announced that Avengers
movie which would be Avengers five it
would overshadow everything all the
focus would be on there and we wouldn't
have as much focus on the cause like
some characters are getting their
sequels some of them again there's
spin-offs with their Disney Plus shows
for the first time exactly and I feel
like we would all just focus on that
team-up who's gonna be the ultimate
villain in that Avengers movie so I
think that's really clever
I'm excited for the diversity that we're
getting with these characters you know
like the the cosmic stuff I'm excited
for I'm also a little bit cautious about
of a little bit cautious I think I've
been nailing it for the most part I get
a lot of crap for this not a big fan of
guard as the galaxy - but guards of the
galaxy one is one of my top five
favorite Marvel movies which is weird
Captain Marvel I thought was alright
Thor Ragnarok is is great and I know
they want to go like way more cosmic
this time internals especially I'm more
excited I'm excited to see if they
really do hone in a little bit more on
the god elements of things that's
something that I don't think Marvel has
like this they launched Thor and they
didn't really they oh the Thor went into
guardians territory in terms of tone and
style and being more of a cosmic space
movie and I and I feel like you know
even though DC is a little bit more
known for its gods of the universe this
is their chance to really explore the
gods of the universe and also introduce
the villain
well that could take on the likes of
someone like Santos you know one on one
well I think you need to I think it's
cool that we don't have an Avengers
announcement just yet because it's yeah
it gets you thinking about who the new
heroes are and stuff and now I feel like
it behooves you to have a good length of
time before you introduce another Thanos
scale villain you know yeah because the
movies all have to be tempered and have
to be on different scales otherwise
we're gonna get you know played out yes
so yeah I mean that's what excites me
the most same way is like I'm happy that
they are really spreading things around
and really giving all of their new or
things that they're expanding on a
chance to be in the spotlight and to get
that focus even on the TV side which is
an experiment and we're excited to see
them take some experiments in format
here and the main thing I'm hoping for
that I don't have a great sense for yet
is some kind of stylistic broadening out
as well yeah that's true because they
have you know like you know the uniform
style of Marvel films in the uniform
look and feel has is necessary in a way
but I feel like there's still room to
get dynamic and explore within that that
they could be tapping so my most excited
level is Kumail Nanjiani being in the
MCU I feel like it could receiver the
MCU and it's finally gonna really pan
out this well this time yeah I also
would Shane cheap I'm just excited
because I've mentioned this before and I
know most you guys haven't heard this
I'm half asian that's why but I am it's
when I was at WonderCon I was on a movie
fights panel and WonderCon the way they
vote at Comic Con T I wasn't part of the
comic-con panel registers from watching
like movie fights usually they just vote
for whatever answer they heard and then
when they were just like the most right
I'm just gonna say that to just catch my
own ego you want you want but I the
question was which MCU villain should do
division why people are Jesus no the
question was which MCU villain should
get a second chance you get another
opportunity to return this was before
Captain Marvel came out so run
the accuser was coming back and that was
a huge deal no no is that no runner
already came back it was after Captain
Marvel but then so I went up against Red
Skull I pitched Mandarin cuz I was like
well you know they had the Marvel
one-shot which said there's a real
Mandarin out there at Kevin Feige has
talked about they're bringing back the
real Mandarin and then also the the ten
rings I know that Mandarin has the power
of the ten rings but also the ten rings
terrorist organization which was such a
big launching point from Iron Man 1 and
even Ben Kingsley's Iron Man 3 character
was you know in linkage with with ten
rings and we never got resolution on
that and I was like so is this terrorist
organization just still out there and
we're not gonna wrap this up so I didn't
even know other things to care about it
cuz I got bigger problems now but so I
think bringing like this new kind of
world was change he brought back into
like earth world but also wrapping up
the the ten rings organization or you
know at least continuing in a more
in-depth way and also I think it was
smart because I know Mandarin is
accredited as being like what an Iron
Man is Iron Man's arch-nemesis I think
if you're gonna bring the manner and
make him an Asian character it's best
that you also have Asian protagonist if
we can see because the Mandarin I think
they didn't make him an Asian character
a lot of because of some racist
stereotypes that were associated with
him
I like the foo Manchu kind of qualities
so I think they can really make it more
culturally appropriate for today so yeah
that's uh that's the we spent a long
time yeah you talked barbel you're gonna
dive deep into this young man what are
the just Woodson but how do I feel about
how do we feel about the four upcoming
avatar sequels John I am aware that
they're coming and for some reason I
don't ever expect him to show up first I
don't know why I you know I'm at this
point curious just because of how long
this is taken and how dedicated James
Cameron is and I don't know
I'm not like excited to per say but I'm
very curious yes whenever James Cameron
comes back he always blows our minds
with some kind of technical achievement
or at least something that was worth
going out to a big spectacular theatre
presentation to see so that's what I'm
saying well for you guys who are in the
livestream they ask cars car lover is
that this let me ask you do you think
avatar 2 has a chance at beating
Avengers endgame in the box office I
want to see I want to hear what
everyone's saying in the chat please
answer that question answer that
question so we got a saucy - 5 she's
real she's real she's real thoughts on
her - pretty sure this whole thing in
the last life got some Bert you know
it's guys I'd it's ok
speaking from Marvel 2 now DC I recently
purchased the DC's the DC app it's the
streaming service app but not to watch
their shows because I'm wrapping up the
boys I got it to check out the people
really [ __ ] people are really to answer
your question um I
well first off what are more of the
details on these birds of prey reshoots
if anyone wants to chime in I'm talking
and reading at the same time I got the
DC streaming service app because I heard
you get pretty much all their comics on
there and if you guys want to catch up
on DC Comics the way they've organized
this app is incredible like the way you
can go through it a page I don't know
exactly how to describe it but I decided
I was like alright what have I not read
I haven't read any of birds of prey and
they have a movie coming out so let me
read some birds of prey so I so from one
of the more recent issue series I start
reading I read two comics last night and
I think it's really freaking cool so for
me I'm like yeah I mean I don't really
have any specific reshoots are common I
feel like people often freaked out about
reshoots but now more than ever now that
I got the DC streaming service out for
the comic books I am I'm so I can't wait
for probably shoot I hope they don't
have a bowl on trailer until I'm done
with reading this whole series that's
the one that so those are basically my
thoughts
on it Plus Margot Robbie returns Harley
Quinn what's there not to be excited
about Eric Eric Eric thank you buddy
what childhood movie would you choose
for a lame-ass reboot and what volume of
anger would you respond to it they if
they rebooted like mrs. Doubtfire that
would be I would be much time i inner
child would be pretty perplexed
I feel like I feel mrs. Doubtfire it
would definitely piss people off because
that character's so so so Robin Williams
and he has passed I feel like for this
answer would be comedies because
especially for comedy films back then
like bloopers liar liar no no I was
gonna say Ace Ventura whew if you
rebooted Ace Ventura like without you
Carrie no you don't do that and I feel
like people would the way people felt
about Ghostbusters I think I would be on
that train okay if you did it with a
girl that amazement or a child or
something I feel like they made that
film yeah I feel like I feel like that
exists Junior they did make an Ace
Ventura Junior oh my god yes oh no jr.
or Ace Ventura three what oh [ __ ] oh man
oh go ahead of you we're talking about
it in the car screws four whoa that must
have been straight-to-dvd right oh god
that's terrible
oh that's terrible JB Bonifacio they ran
on Cartoon Network and it was
live-action them that's weird
yes okay what did we JB boo-boos you
guys read house of X or powers of X
thoughts I love the best comic ever
powers is way better than the powers in
house of Y or Z totally overrated
X's where it's X is where it's at JB let
me tell you I'm so glad you brought this
up because it is the greatest thing ever
I love powers of X is better than house
of X lip threw it so fast you can have a
past life like powers
easy breezy lemon squeeze covergirl
alright guys we're gonna wrap up this
live stream thanks for hopping on to
this one with us we'll take a couple
more just random questions John choose a
random question from there scroll Scroll
scroll do you guys imagine every
midnight lawnmower man reboot oh wait
that would actually work dude that's the
point you should be with reboots is like
reboots stuff that was like already kind
of kooky or - Joker or not Michael
Conway well I don't think this Joaquin
Phoenix Joker is in the same universe as
bad as Matt Reeves Batman first off I
just can't imagine Joaquin Phoenix
signing on for like an 8 picture deal I
mean do you guys know walking Phoenix I
just don't think you would do that you
know and he would get himself fired yeah
I think it's really smart to just steer
clear from Joker in the next Batman
movie I don't feel like Joker should be
in any first Batman movie except for I
noticed the Tim Burton one but think
about it the Tim Burton one who was the
one everyone talked about the Joker and
he put the Joker in any of them he's
gonna be the most talked about even in
Suicide Squad the most praised
characters were Harley Quinn and
Deadshot but what everyone talked about
Jared Leto and their very strong opinion
on the Joker dedicated to a character
who barely affected them yes
dream choice to play Batman Hugh Jackman
mm-hmm Henry Golding I think Henry
Golding would be a good Superman he's
getting a lot of work now and I've
always wanted to see him as a good as a
Superman uh yeah um II think that Fox
should still release new mutants after
dark
yes yes let's see that well there's what
do they have to lose at this point just
put it on Netflix put it on this is the
bus service just put it out there put on
Hulu oh man I just love these reports
that are coming out about like you know
Disney execs are watching these Fox
movies it's it's at this point where I'm
like who cares put it yeah spent the
time you can make some we all know it's
gonna suck you just put it out there and
this point it might be like fine and by
this point that might be great because
we're all expecting it to be horrible
what do we hit what are they worried
about at this point like okay if you
don't put it in the theaters that's a
bummer for the filmmakers and they cast
and everyone involved yeah absolutely
but clearly they have zero interest in
putting it in the theaters and if they
put it in the theaters at this point
it's gonna tank so put it on streaming
services just put it out there let
people watch it as I still want to watch
it even if it's like this terrible [ __ ]
it on movie [ __ ] it as long as it's out
there finally I'm fascinated and that's
why I want to see it's okay
yeah me too I'm pretty much at that same
point I'm pretty much at that same point
anyway guys look we're gonna wrap this
up right now Jen hey Jen hey do I just
reply back to your message so I wanted
to end this with one more dope trope you
know I'll probably start off the next
live stream this is most people make it
to the end of the live stream so I'm
gonna start off the next dope trope with
this one and here's what it is when
someone is falling from like a building
or a plane and then action hero jumps
off and then puts their arms back and
somehow it makes them fall faster that's
not how gravity works that doesn't make
any sense well I think there are ways
you can affect how aerodynamically
you're falling in midair I'm not a
professional have you ever seen it's
physics John not as extent work that way
heightened in the movies but I think
that's based on a real concept because
if your arms are splayed you're gonna
fall slower than if you make yourself
aerodynamic if you dropped a watermelon
and an egg which one would hit the
ground first
into this part of the car they would hit
well yeah what they're doing the sky you
can do it not how I don't know if you've
ever guys defending terrible action
movies I'm not defending the movies
themselves and this thing I think is
based on something kind of conceptually
plausible and that is dope trope number
two anyway guys thanks for being here
much love thank you to everyone who
contributed super chat thank you
everyone who's asked questions and
viewed along yeah I don't know just seem
fun to go live again and it's fun going
live it's fun
Jean Jeter check out his channel oh we
smash